let's go to alicia in new york city so
i'm lucky enough that at work
i got picked for a fast track program
very cool
that's the upside what's what's that
what's the fast track program like a
leadership track or something
yes dude way to go alicia
thank you thank you
and in this leadership program they
shoot us like you don't you sound really
sad
no the thing is i i believe me i'm
excited you know we're gonna get to
travel and there's a lot of
good things coming for it's a huge
opportunity however i cannot wrap my
head around the public speaking aspect
oh no are you glossophobic you don't
like speaking in public
oh it's it's happened late like in the
last
few years i was never i don't think i
was ever this nervous
but it has gotten terrible are you
nervous
now because you're telling like you are
talking to well there's only like 38
listeners
we doubled in the last week does this
make you nervous being on the show
or is that cool a little bit okay a
little bit a little bit all right
so walking me through you're on a stage
is it big crowds or little crowds or any
crowds
oh my god on a stage i think i i'd pass
out um
i think it's just i think it's
especially when it's work
i think it's because i put so much
pressure on myself that
i have to be on point at all times okay
so you know where does that come where
does that come from alicia
um probably because i was a young mom
okay so i've had to basically
do everything have you been able to do
everything
sorry oh you're good have you been able
no no
no no i'm not letting you get away with
luck
that's one of those things that single
moms do to
not be able to look in the mirror and
say hey you know what's up i'm
so dope i'm alicia from nyc
and i run this town
no i it's not luck i've worked your butt
off haven't you
yes and you're real smart aren't you
yes and you grow and raised you grew and
raised a human
and still managed to be on the
leadership track right
yes and i bet your baby loves you too
huh
yes i'm very blessed no
i mean you are but you're also a good
mom too right
yeah i i do anything for them
ah so cool all right so you put a lot
into this
and you're the higher ups wherever you
work have said man you're the future of
this place and we're going to invest
in you and there's a part of you that's
like yeah that's what's up and there's
another part of you
it's like oh no they're going to find
out
is that fair you know yes that is pretty
accurate
and you can you how many kids you have
i have two you can raise two
humans and just i'm gonna do this
you know if
the thought of raising two kids by
myself that makes me want to not be
alive
and you just handle that with grace and
dignity and power and strength
getting on a stage is simple man that's
just act you can be a clown up there
right
so when you think of getting on a stage
have you ever just gotten up to give a
speech and just
blown it just completely
wet the bed on it not that awful though
i think i've stumbled and you know said
a couple things that you know of course
i would have done differently but no not
never got off stage and your co-workers
are like that's the last time you're
ever gonna do that
no i have i have
and i do this for a living right
are you still there sorry yes i lost you
for a second what was that last question
i thought you said i'm out of here
i said no no no i'm saying i was asking
have you ever screwed up so bad that
your co-workers said hey you can never
speak here again
no okay i have and i do speaking for a
living that's my job
okay all right so tell me what are you
terrified of like what do you think's
gonna gonna happen happen
i think it's just a failure the not
living up to
okay especially now right now i'm in
this now it's like oh my god now you
have to just maintain and keep going
and and i i'm an over preparer okay
i will i will you know prepare
and read over and look at everything and
try to prepare for all the questions and
i think my biggest fear is that there's
a question that i don't have the answer
to
i'm going to teach you a magic magic
phrase you ready
while you're talking about being an over
preparer i'm watching james and kelly
they're just rolling their eyes back
there they're like wow that must be nice
to work with someone who actually
prepares
here's a magic phrase okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna save you a million dollars
ready repeat after me
i don't know i'm gonna find that out
i don't know i'm gonna find that out you
see look at that
dude we were solving problems on this
show all right so here's the thing about
glossophobia that's just the nerd term
for fear of speaking in public right
it is uh i've never read the direct
study but anecdotally
um it's repeated often enough that i'm
gonna consider a fact for the time being
that it is the most common phobia people
are
more scared of speaking in public than
they are of actually being
dead okay and for somebody who speaks in
public for a living
i can't wrap my head around that but i
do i can't
hear it enough to know here folks like
you that are like i would never
ever get on that stage and and do that
so does preparing wear you out or is it
exciting
is it fun um
i like i like getting you know when i
start feeling comfortable like okay i
got this like you know i'm here i got
that i got that but
yes i do get worn out sometimes okay so
a couple of things i want you to know
number one
i was working here and you know the name
dave ramsey is that name ring a bell
yes okay it was like three o'clock or
four o'clock in the afternoon i just
finished
filming some stuff and i was about to
leave and there was a small
event this is right before cove kicked
off there's a small event
that was going to take place on a
saturday up here at the building that
they were filming for a video shoot
and wouldn't you know it that on stage
at three or four in the afternoon
was not only dave ramsey but also my
buddy chris hogan
who both of them have spoke like done
live events in front of
millions of people and there was a small
stage they were both on it they were
both
facing opposite directions and they were
practicing
a talk they were going to give to a
couple hundred people and that's when i
realized
oh that's what the greats do they
practice
they prepare and i had just been a guy
that would write down a speech on the
back of an
envelope as i'm walking up on stage and
it's gotten me by
but i realized whoa this is a whole
other level of preparation
and so you've already got that right
you've already got
the part where i need to make sure i
know what i'm going to say
the people in the audience i want to be
a steward of the most precious resource
on earth they have and that's their time
but 30 minutes an hour that you're
giving that talk they can never have
that time back i'm going to be a steward
i'm going to practice i'm going to know
i'm going to say
and so then from there i'm going to give
you a couple things that can help you on
stage okay
and then a couple things off of it all
right so
i'm ready think of public speaking
not as a lecture but as a conversation
when i switched from thinking i had to
give
info because i was just having a
conversation with folks
everything my heart rate changed my
shoulders changed all my physiology
changed because
what i was doing in my body was
different i wasn't
talking at people i wasn't teaching at
people i was just talking to folks
and it just shifted and suddenly i've
given the same talk to 10 people around
a table that i've given to a thousand
people in an auditorium
it becomes the same thing because i'm
having a conversation i can adjust it by
people and size
but it changes my whole heart right and
the speakers i've met that i love the
most
on stage are very similar to who they
are off stage
so instead of thinking it as a
performance as a make or break
is now i'm you know i'm a backstreet boy
or i'm jay-z like i gotta go up and like
the lights are on
i mean i was having a conversation
backstage i was having a conversation
with three people i'm gonna go have a
conversation with 300 people on stage
it just shifts the entire your entire
physiology right
and then as things get more magnified
and bigger your heart state will stay
your heart rate will stay the same you
know you're going to talk about you're
prepared
right you're way ahead of me alicia and
then just becomes about
and i bet are you real funny my guess is
you
are real funny like dry witty
someone's gonna say something and you
will just do mic drop after mic dropped
with your friend group is that fair
i can yes i can be very quick see
if there's something that is completely
non-work related i'm
i'm it's totally different that i'm like
i'm game let's do this but when it's
work related it's like
oh my gosh okay okay so here's here's
where that anxiety gap is
is the gap between you who's the person
that your company hired
you who is hilarious and your friends
love
and you're trying to put a space between
them and i want you to close that space
and i want you to be
you everywhere because the world needs
to hear about single moms who are
awesome and get put on leadership tracks
right right you've got some you've got
some wisdom to share
that me and my community here that
you're working needs to hear that the
world needs to hear right
is that fair yeah
your company is paying to make you
better
they are fast tracking you how can we
get her in front of more people
quicker that's how much they invest how
much they think you're good right
so i want you to close that gap and i
want you to be witty and funny in
conversation with your buddies at the
bar
the same way you got two kids you're not
at the bar the same way like at wherever
at daycare whatever i don't know where
you happen to be
going from place to place um and i want
you to be that same person on a stage
and they are going to eat you up and
that just
has to do with i'm gonna have
conversation i'm not performing right
here's the second thing
the the nerd word is exposure therapy
that's just a fancy way for saying
you got to put yourself in situations
where you got to do it
and that can look like signing up for
different kinds of speeches
all different kinds of places if there's
a
moms group a education group on
saturdays if it's a church group
whatever that looks like wherever you
can
get in front of folks to practice this
skill
of just being who you are off stage walk
up on stage heart rate never changes i'm
just gonna have a conversation
man you're gonna get better and better
and better at it because when you talk
to 10 you can talk to a thousand
if you can talk to a thousand or you can
talk to a hundred you can talk to five
thousand it's easier that way because
man they are more distant and further
along right
and then here's the final thing find
your humor in everyday moments and take
it on stage with you
give me a funny joke right now you can
do it do it make me laugh alicia
oh my god what's the funniest thing your
kid has done recently
oh my kid's in his 20s so they just
can't you know my kids are in their 20s
so they make fun of me all
constantly so oh there's their 20s come
on man you are at the bar
all right so what's one thing that make
you laugh
what's one thing they do that makes me
laugh yes
oh when they just do imitations of of
how i raise them
okay so here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna take those imitations of
how they raise you and you're going to
imitate them
imitating you and that's going to be an
awesome lead into your
to any sort of um talk you're going to
give and
everyone in the audience is going to
either have had parents that they
imitate and mock
or they're going to have kids they're
tired of imitating them right it's the
whole you're man you're gonna build
rapport with that with that audience
find places to practice be who you're
gonna be off stage
on stage just have a conversation with
folks and more importantly
know this your company would not be
investing in you if they didn't think
you were the right person
here i want you to hang on the line
alicia i'm going to give you a copy of
this book redefining anxiety this any
sort of phobia
tends to manifest itself when these in
this
this anxiety especially this this
situational anxiety
i want you to check this book out read
it um everybody else out there books 10
bucks
it's easy read if you can't read this
book's for you
if you're really smart fancy pants is
for sure for you because you're not that
i'm just kidding
but yeah check it out it's 10 bucks you
can get it on johndaloney.com but
alicia hang on the line and we're going
to mail you a free copy here